oddio ci credo oddio arrivo dobbiamo
trovare le cose strane nelle foto
scoprirle cosa tranne vedere le cose
strane e si 8 brufolo infante a uscire
ovunque ma perché proprio in fronte al
centro della fronte
oggi sono uscita a comprare la nutella
sì perché la tutte le suscita
appositamente per coprire la nutella e
la cassiera mi ha guardato e mi ha
sorpreso tipo forse hai già mangiato
troppo
siete pronti vediamo se riuscite a
trovare che così buio riesco a trovare
più cose io scrive rete anche quelle
vostre risposte nei commenti come sempre
mettetevi comodi patatine pop corn un tè
freddo acqua fresca frutta e verdura
vero che ogni cosa vi scrivo a te mente
che li faccia ingrassare le prigioni e
iniziamo subito si foto numero uno cosa
c'è di strano in questa foto
allora ci sono due signori mariti e
mogli madri davanti qua abbiamo degli
alberi a qualche cosa strana nella mano
qualcosa su cui l'avete già notato
scrivetelo nei commenti
no mi sembra normale il loro due
vediamo ma se quando il laghetto cosa
stanno facendo questi due non è dedichi
anima li spiano sembrano un nasino forse
sono due casi ok
penso che la cosa strana siano questi
giocare vediamo perché esistono le
opzioni qua la prima opzione animali
seconda fantasmi terza un corpo in acqua
quarta qualcuno che si nasconde negli
alberi allora non mi sembra che si
stiano solo che si nasconde gli altri li
più ovvio questo con gli animali vediamo
se è giusto ovviamente per la vostra
risposta nei commenti si erano gli
animali che pensavo questo a volte
dicono sicuramente sono cavi vediamo la
prossima foto case cosa c'è di strano in
questa foto su quando il cane sia
qualche strano ma no il cane che normale
se avete già visto cosa c'è di strano
scrivetelo nei commenti o mio dio
aspetta allora questo il braccio del
padre e dovrebbe finire quale grazie
giusto o meno che non è come quella
incredibili facciano mano però le mani
del bambino sono qua non mia idea di chi
è quella mano inquietante non può essere
del padre e qui piccolina a aiuto
quando le distanze lo avete notato
rimetterlo vediamo le funzioni cosa
dicono gli astri dicono una persona
nascosta che non mi sembra come che non
è nascosta nel un extra braccio un extra
gamba o un cane nascosto quindi direi
braccio anche se lei non vedo nessun
extra tracks vedo solo un'esca mano
comunque vediamo se è giusto si può che
vediamo in questa foto
cosa c'è di strano oddio accordo già
visto per i tre non l'avete già notato
anche voi perché salta subito all'occhio
scegliete di strano con le ragazze ma
l'avete notato
scrivetelo nei commenti beh cosa strana
è qua dietro sono tutti uguali
ovviamente non penso che
in realtà fossero tutti uguali ma penso
che qualcuno abbia preso abbiamo
photoshoppato la sua faccia la forza di
qualcun altro più volte dietro allora le
opzioni sono animali fantasmi potrebbero
essere dei fantasmi questi cloni
maschili o cloni femminili ma come cloni
femminili come può essere una ragazza
quel camero che non penso che queste
ragazze tutte uguali ma tra diverse così
rimasta anche voi avete scritto che
saranno fatti uomini tutti uguali tanti
ragazzi tutti uguali avete indovinato
ma perché hanno tutti gli occhiali
questi bambini tranne lei anzi si
rientra nelle mie due
vabbè avete notato cosa c'è di strano
[Musica]
quindi se avete già notato questa serie
di strano ma ho notato che in questo
bambino sta facendo un gesto poco carino
con le mani di espressione soddisfatta
ancora più bella
espressione soddisfatta riuscito a
mascherarsi benissimo non lo scopriranno
mai finché non riguarderanno la foto
quindi materie che si affretta a lato fa
sembravano ammettiamo lingo scarna che
vuol dire quel gestori con il dito medio
in questo oppure qualcuno che si sta
scolando oppure qualcuno che sta tirando
un pugno a un paio di cross e non mi
sembra proprio quello che fa finta di
dormire
oddio non so se effettivamente su colpo
anche partite di dormire no non mi
sembra quindi decisamente e flipping o
vediamo se avete notato subito io questo
su questo può farlo ora l'unica cosa un
po strana e impalmato qua dietro ma non
so se sia la cosa principale nella foto
qui strano che stanno forse persone
fatta lavorando su e questo non capisco
cosa sta facendo bene sta guardando
perso l'unica cosa strana sera il
pagliaccio un'inquietante qua dietro
vediamole oltre che cosa dicono allora
vampiro pagliaccio una persona si
nasconde e un fantasma di re il
pagliaccio vediamo si giusto era il
pagliaccio o che qua c'è scritto già
nella foto mi ci sono voluti dieci
minuti per capire cosa c'era di strano
di sbagliato in questa foto
allora vediamo un po ma come 10 minuti
poi dieci minuti a capirlo allora vi
lascio un pochino di tempo
questo sicuramente lo sapete
l'atterraggio sulla luna sulla luna
avete capito
nei commenti la luna a quanti avranno
aggiunto quest'anno un'acqua comunque a
primo impatto in realtà però aperto la
foto la prima volta che mi è saltata
all'occhio è che è un altro fosse un po
troppo cicciottella sicuramente la punta
tra le opzioni che abbiamo sono la
bandiera la luna l'astronauta o il palo
che è la bandiera
ovviamente la lunga ke cosa c'è di male
in questo
[Musica]
oddio no no visto che c'era una persona
o non capisco se l'hanno modificata se
sotto il coppo se questa persona è così
bianca riflettente che non si vede
niente come ray in spiaggia la succede
la stessa cosa scompaio della fame di
anche mario che la nostra sia questa
persona quassù per bianca poi non so mi
è stata dallo che anche il fatto che
questa sede è dritta e appoggiate al
alla ringhiera tipo perché si nasconde
cariche si nasconde il gatto che si
nasconde il fantasma che si nasconde
allora io in questa voterei fantasma che
si nasconde perché
sembra un fantasma che otto persone che
si nasconde esatto se the rich
chiamatela subito quali sono un sacco di
dettagli quindi un po più complicato
oddio ho appena visto mi sono spaventata
allora guardate bene volete bene poi
spostate piano piano quanto a tutte
queste gabbiette farina
all'inizio pensavo ci fosse qualcosa di
strano nell'orologio 9 script se il cane
ha passato al cosino della porta è
troppo caro per un pò inquietante oddio
tellino cane ajaccio fantasma ma se ci
fosse un fantasma come faremo a vederlo
comunque cane giusto passiamo alla
prossima mattina oddio
penso che abbiano rubato il la parte di
sopra del bikini a questa ragazza
scambiati anche la parte di stop
comunque decisamente la casa storia di
questa foto è questo allora cane
fantasma sempre questo fantasma non
capisco ma voi avete visto un fantasma
in queste foto magari ci sarà qualche
fantasma in contatto oppure uomo giusto
prossima foto di gruppo viaggia ok quasi
capisco praticamente subito questa sede
di strano e nina vedete qua dietro
questa ragazza sta accadendo ma non è
che sta accadendo poco poco magari ha
preso una piccola storta sta proprio
volando giù dalle scale che era
probabilmente a pazzo a terra e questi
ragazzi hanno fatto l'appunto dietro in
tempo e hanno colto questo splendido
romantico momento nello sfondo era
vediamo questo le altre opzioni entrato
non so perché ma questo ragazzo vestito
con lei mi ricorda latin fossero un
cosplay
comunque le opzioni sono qualcuno che
piange
allora lei piangerà sicuramente dopo
qualcuno che sanguina lo stesso piacerà
dopo qualcuno che dorme
no è qualcuno che sta accadendo
purtroppo state poverina imago 86 di
strano per sabato
a parte il fatto come fanno a starci in
cinque in una vasca da bagno o con
michael brandt come sono messi allora
questa ragazza ha la gamba qua l'altra
gamba forse qua sotto
questa campo di chiedere a dio
questa gamba scuola e piede e di questa
ragazza invece questa si capisce dove a
tre gamberi piedi è questa oddio allora
pensate a quello che si rifiutano questa
foto siano le gambe ei piedi che non si
capiscono se nostro controllabili addio
no o mio dio inquietantissimo ragazzi
guardate bene quello che bene
poco prima favoriti ma soprattutto
perché mi stavo concentrando solamente
nelle gambe e si in piedi questo è
spostato un po la visuale
l'avete visto avete visto il piccolo da
dove qualsiasi sono le ragazze ecco se
si fa un mostro con pantano guardate qua
c'è la mano e questa è la faccia perché
sia photoshoppato che non sia una
fotografia 23 banche
comunque le opzioni solo a me lo avete
visto subito se avete messo un po di
tempo come me allora la prima opzione
che si intravede qualcosa nelle ragazze
secondo tom che spia le ragazze non so
se si può chiamare tom questa cosa
perché a me sembra un tema
e cioè ma questi non sono tipo i denti è
una persona normale oppure un animale
che si nasconde o la vasca che si rompe
forse tra un po si romperà la vasca con
cinque persone entro onde
il fatto che abbia un nome questa
persona mi fa pensare che la foto
scadere non potevo fatta ma mi chiedo
come faccia tom adattare questo aspetto
inquietante ottima cosa
in questa foto per lì sembra abbastanza
ovvio nel mezzo dello sfumato c'è il
succhietto sta comunque tenendo
strumento con il suo piede
non so come abbia fatto di essere un
politico ma forse è facile comunque le
opzioni sono un naso ma ad un piede
orecchio piede giusto prossimo aiuto non
so perché queste nella foresta mi fanno
paura perché paura di vedere qualche
modo si trova proprio nella foresta tv
lo sono adesso mimetizza tissima
guardate bene guardate bene guardate
bene dovete cristo ecco
vediamo quali sono le opzioni un affila
un elefante una tirata un coyote
decisamente una t roba veramente ci
sarebbe qualcosa da illuminare qua
veramente e che ovvio c'è una ciabatta
con una pistola
spero finta appello flip flop come la
flic floc ovviamente costerà molto
facile ragazzi che si sono vestiti in
modo veramente strano c'è lui ha un bel
costume non si è cosplay di qualcuno
però l'uomo aragosta così così e poi c'è
l'uomo leone ma forse la bestia della
bella e la bestia un cuore rivedere un
altro fantasma dietro bovo ma avete
trovato voi non trovo niente ott io ci
credo perché i ragazzi l'ho visto adesso
lo avete visto quello che bene guardate
bene questa è una persona guardate passo
la faccia questo immagino che sia nel
costume e sta tenendo in mano questo
questa specie di piante in pratica il
vestito di coda pianta ma e mimetizzati
stimo 5 o mio dio
allora le opzioni sono in questo caso la
domanda era quante persone ci sono in
questa foto quindi direi 48 prossimo e
qua c'è scritto quando persone ci sono
sul divano quindi andiamo affrontarle
123456 ho visto che sia finta questa
foto in cui tantissimo
l'avete visto volete bene in questo bene
quello che bene penso che sia finta
comunque sembra abbastanza finta perché
il resto ricotta non si vede comunque
pinzolo 7 giusto
avete notato qualcosa o addio non esiste
allora le sta tracciando lui e lui ci
sono due mai qua in realtà questo penso
che sia un guantone umano sembra che un
guanto quindi direi che c'è una mano in
più vediamo petizione sono mano in più
piede in più poi anche in più ok ma più
prossimo oddio avete visto verrà sebbene
parete bene l'avesse notata nella foto
c'è scritto giorno 34 ancora
notato tanto relative rate per queste
parrucchetti questo è un po troppo
realistica no infatti penso che questa
sia una vera persona oppure un manichino
super e iper realistico allora qua
vincono quante di queste persone
quanti di questi manichini sono in
realtà umani ma io penso solo questo non
penso
questi è possibile che siano umani
quindi direi uno giusta un prossimo
non riesco a trovare niente di male a
tenere corso
a cominciare un cane permette enorme
labate notato subito su avete messo un
po
e infatti la funzione è camere ragazzi
alla camera sia scala del sistema rosso
la ti voglio proprio bene camera fateci
sapere se volete vedere un secondo
episodio di questa serie è troppo le
cose
la foto mi sono divertita un sacco messa
in piazza stacco giocare con voi
se ne volete la giustizia dello stato un
bel laiche 10.000 likes pronto per però
andrà aria o mio dio
andrò a fare la seconda parte ora vi
lascio 4 catherine hsu più potete
cliccare per vedere i miei prossimi di
quello che preferite e buona visione
no